what's up with you I'm set as if slip
zip slip to your zip slip is I I know
what was that so you're standing there
in the bathroom at the urinal junior
thing thinking about whatever life
reflecting not really paying attention
he waits he done shake it off
zip it up full
[Music]
how could you think that would happen
not saying it's gonna happen but like I
don't know if you're not paying
attention or someone shifts
wait dude can we just take the stairs be
serious okay
so imagine this so you get an elevator
but you notice there's like an
uncomfortable jump and you think
yourself while the doors are closing
it's probably fine the doors closed boom
you plummet 35 floors to your net or
you're stuck in there you hit the button
nothing
hit it again crickets phone service out
you scream you scream again but louder
nobody's coming for you everybody's
forgotten about you've been in there two
weeks there's no food there's no water
you have to eat your own leg or the
sensor that's supposed to stop before it
crushes you doesn't activate your arm
gets crackle crunch swoosh you're stuck
in there as it goes down to the floor
below you would rip your body in half
let's just take the stairs
thank you eat like five hose so guys
what's up guys you see that what so you
see a group of people you know you walk
by say hello then you notice a little
sound some snickering going on behind
you you take a peek they're definitely
looking at you I'm not a lip reader but
I'm definitely seeing my name Ben Ben
why are they laughing
wait is he pointing at me poop points
what have I done to deserve this
I don't know where all these thoughts
come from in maybe they stem from some
like deeper to fear of death I have like
you smell something strange in your
apartment oh [ __ ] I was supposed to
switch out the batteries of a carbon
monoxide up doesn't matter you're dead
or you're on a tall building or on a
ledge we're high up do you ever get this
strange bird to just jump I mean not
that I would not that I want to jump but
this thought just kind of pops into my
mind it's not that I'm considering it
it's more that I'm just wondering what
it's like not that I want to die no you
just kind of think to yourself what if
hey you okay ma'am yeah let's see I have
another one though do you know when you
miss your period exactly I don't know
how but every time I miss my period I
think I'm pregnant and I haven't had sex
with a guy for ten years like I'm super
gay like I'm married to a woman yet
every time I miss my period
you still think you're pregnant I get
you how do you get her you've never had
a period before I get your thought
process like anxiety is scary yeah we
give anymore and for some reason I just
can't hit the brakes do you know I'm
talking about
I know exciting a way to tell me about
what about Harris trainers because every
time I use them I believe that I didn't
upload them and the hell just burns down
and my wife finds out and then she
leaves me she dies in the fire or she
dies it could happen okay I'm gonna go
to work or something all right later
yeah
but downer I notice what you do with it
I don't know since we call it a simple
Steve
holster I like that I'm gonna need to
write a face who cares that's simple
sphere
[Music]